les traces de l'accident de samedi sont
encore visibles sur la piste de voiture
entrée en collision
pas de victime mais des dégâts matériels
importants et des employés partagé entre
peur et exaspération
c'est plus inquiétant c'est inquiétant
travail parce que mon pour le monde will
come on ou de fruits inattendu à ce
centre dès qu'on entend un coup de frein
c'est toujours la même chose on
l'appelle vallat et le dernier accident
qui l'a utre dernier j'étais là j'étais
présent j'étais paniquée voilà et tous
les jours en subissant des voitures qui
traversent à toute vitesse là on n'en
peut plus
il faut que la population respecte son
lieu de travail c'est pas unique
ce matin la station est restée fermée
depuis samedi soir les employés exercent
leur droit de retrait c'est le troisième
accident de l'année en 2017
j'osais niger un jeune pompiste avait
perdu la vie fauchée par une voiture
depuis voici la seule solution apporter
un ralentisseur installé là par la
direction il y a quelques mois et rien
d'autre ces passagers ya aucune réponse
dans la mesure qui a nourri dian qui a
été fait et dont il y avait des
propositions qui devait tête et ont été
faites mais l'évolution on devrait se
rencontrer le vert le 20 novembre le 20
novembre assez basta ya rien est apte au
regard de 32 39 ans et a eu un accident
corps ou les lie en gros pôles rdc
pousse cette logique en somme ça c'est
d'arrêter de travail la ctm là ça mc
propriétaire du terrain et la préfecture
se sont en effet rencontrés il ya deux
mois sans pouvoir apporter jusqu'à ce
jour une réponse concrète à la
quarantaine d'employés de la station
service